Tout le mécanisme est bloqué, et les 5 chambres sont chargées
Tout d'abord, on retire les plaques de bois pour accéder au ressort principal
La partie dangereuse : On garde la tête loin
La munition date de l'époque (1880)
On effectue une électrolyse pour retirer le rouille (la solution est composée d'eau et de sel)
Le courant électrique circule du revolver (cathode) à l'anode (la coutellerie) qui reçoit la rouille.
Au bout de 3 heures
Dégraisser le métal avec de l'acétone
Cette fois, on va cuivrer le métal à l'aide d'une nouvelle électrolyse. La solution est cette fois composée de vinaigre blanc et de sel
Le processus doit être lent et ne pas générer trop d'ébullition, sinon il y aura dépôt
La solution vire au bleu avec le sulfate de cuivre
Regardez comme le cuivre s'est déposé !
Maintenant on peut utiliser le même procédé pour ajouter une couche de nickel sur le cuivre (il n'est pas possible de nickeler directement sur l'acier)
Même procédé pour l'autre pièce
Fabrication de rivets pour fixer les éléments du revolver
Bleuissage à froid des éléments que nous faisons ne veut pas
nickeler Appliquer Tiffoo sur métal dégraissé, puis baigner dans de l'eau bouillante
Temps de remontage
N'oubliez pas de graisser
Nous utilisons des munitions à blanc pour tester le mécanisme (fabriqué dans un stand de tir sous la supervision de professionnels).
Abonnez-vous pour plus de contenu comme ça !